dort bei bild sonntags die richtigen
fragen
montag bis freitag viertel nach acht
montag und freitag live ist live
[Musik]
die möglichkeit hineinzugehen
einzig zu haben
hier an den rändern deswegen war es
brennt ist an vielen stellen
bild
[Musik]
also bekommen meine damen und herren zu
einer spezialausgabe von viertel nach
acht fünf köpfe fünf meinungen was haben
sie selbst vor zwei wochen am
mittwochabend gemacht ich weiß noch ich
verlebte einen unbeschwerten abend im
restaurant wachte auf und schicken
europa herrscht ein furchtbares gefühl
heute der stellvertretende chefredakteur
und für den nach trost paul ronzheimer
den ukrainischen präsidenten willen zum
exklusiven interview getroffen diesen
gespräch sagte salewski wenn eine rakete
eine kinderklinik in deutschland treffen
würde was dann stellen sie sich mal uns
in ihrer situation vor man würde
besprechen und verhandeln das ist unser
schmerz heute und ich brauche die lösung
heute wie die lösung aussehen könnte was
sollte die nato tun und wie heiß wird
der neue kalte krieg das möchte ich
heute besprechen mit dem ehemaligen
parteivorsitzende afd jungen leuten cdu
politiker philipp heiß nachdem
stellvertretender chefredakteur paul
ronzheimer live aus kiew und dem
soziologen gerald knaus lassen sie uns
für jeden abend bei vielen nach acht
direkt zur anzahl nach kirsch alten paul
du hast heute den ukrainischen
präsidenten silencing zum exklusiven
interview getroffen und die unter
anderem gefragt gab es während dieses
krieges jemals einen moment in dem ihre
kinder zu und sagte papa lass uns das
land verlassen die russische armee will
dich töten magst uns einmal deine
eindrücke des interviews schildern
janina vielen dank dass sie heute abend
bei viertel nach acht über die situation
hier in der ukraine sprechen kann und
tatsächlich ich war heute nachmittag in
einem präsidentenpalast aber dort sieht
es nicht mehr aus wie ein
präsidentenpalast aus sieht man geht
doch rein das licht ist aus man fällt
fast über die treppe und dann sieht man
überall sandsäcke aufgestellt und man
denkt in jedem moment gibt es hier eine
attacke und plötzlich kommt aus irgend
einem anderen raum bludenz geräumt und
ist erstaunlich entspannt und fragt wie
geht es ihnen eigentlich wie geht es
ihnen denn kehrt aber dann ging es
natürlich um sehr ernste themen ich habe
ihn gefragt wie viel angst der
eigentlich um sein eigenes leben hat und
was mit seinen kindern hat ist seine
älteste tochter ist 18 jahre alt und er
hat gesagt meine kinder sind stolz dass
wir weiterhin hier sind und er will
bleiben er will weiter bleiben in seinem
land und er denkt nicht an eine flucht
um ganz unabhängig davon muss man sagen
dass er erneut ein sehr dramatischen
appell an die westliche welt gerichtet
hat er hat diesen satz gesagt wir
sterben auch für euch seine aussage und
seine meinung ist dass das was gerade in
der ukraine passiert sehr schnell auch
anderen ländern passieren kann dass wenn
putin hier mit der ukraine fertig ist
dass es weiter geht ins baltikum also in
die nato-staaten und immer weiter und
immer weiter deswegen seine mahnung und
warnung und auch wenn er mittlerweile
gelernt hat diplomatisch zu sein habe
ich herausgehört bei ihm wie wütend er
ist auf deutschland wie wütend er ist
auf olaf scholz den kanzler wie wütend
er darauf ist dass es immer noch aus
seiner sicht keine wirklich klare
antwort darauf gibt dass es in sachen
eu-beitritt keine wirkliche schnelle
perspektive gibt und dass aus sicht der
ukraine weiter nicht genügend westliche
waffen hier sind denn das ist das
entscheidende für die ukraine momentan
die frage wie gut können sie sich
verteidigen denn dann kommt es darauf an
wie es am ende bei verhandlungen
aussieht und bei diesen verhandlungen
dass man eine sache nie vergessen
wladimir putin hat vor zwei wochen
ungefähr als dieser krieg begonnen hat
gesagt die ukraine die gibt ist
eigentlich gar nichts gehört zu russland
und das ist der ausgangspunkt von dem
selensky auf dem see lance gesteht wir
saßen dort auch diesen treppen und es
war eine für mich völlig skurrile
absurde situation mit einem präsidenten
ein interview zu führen der natürlich in
so einer situation kein schlips trägt
aber der ja fast camouflage trägt und
wie auf einer treppe sitzen und
rundherum um uns sandsäcke sind
paul du wirst ja immer die großen
interviews mit vielen staatsmännern mit
politikern du bist es ja ein für sich
gewöhnt solche interviews zu führen das
hier war jetzt etwas komplett anderes
was war der emotionalste moment für dich
oder der moment wo du wirklich was sie
lange in erinnerung bleiben wird
die frage nach den kindern von seelands
die weil er auch ein lustiger mensch ist
eigentlich es gibt so tolle videos von
ihnen von früher in der
internationalen version von let's dance
hat er mitgemacht er ist ja eigentlich
zufällig politiker geworden jemand der
immer im showbusiness unterwegs war
komiker war schauspieler war und jetzt
sitzt dieser mann dort in den
präsidentenpalast und ist im krieg und
ich frage ihn was ist mit seinen kindern
was ist wenn die ihm sagen putin will
dich töten papa gesagt nein meine kinder
sind stolz auf mich dass ich hier bin
und sie sind auch hier war das ganze
land hier ist und das drückt aus was die
ukraine momentan fühlt die gesamte
ukraine führt dass sie angegriffen
werden aber dass sie zusammenstehen dass
alle familien zusammen stehen und dass
sie sich die existenz nicht absprechen
lassen
ich würde hier gerne die runde dann
eröffnen weil es uns den ganzen abend
wie immer live zugeschaltet war wie
immer geh einfach auch rein herr heißen
ich würde gerne die frage an sie geben
machen wir genug wenn man das jetzt hört
auch die eindrücke von paul wie verhält
sich deutschland gerade aus ihrer sicht
als cdu politiker also ich glaube wir
mal nicht genug aber erstmal also
wirklich hochachtung vor der
journalistischen leistung von paul
ronzheimer ich habe auf dem weg hierher
mehr dieses interview auch live
angesehen mit dem präsidenten das ist
wirklich enorm beeindruckend und man
fühlt richtig mit auch mit den ukrainern
in dieser schwierigen situation das ist
also ich finde das eine ganz ganz krasse
situation einfach dass wir wieder krieg
in europa haben auch gerade für die
junge generation aber nein wir tun als
deutschland nicht genug und ich warte
wir sind ja im moment als wir müssen
auch wegkommen von dieser gewissen
naivität die wir glaube ich zu lange
hatten gerade im umgang mit putin diese
sogenannten putin verstehe ja das ist
etwas was wir uns einfach überhaupt
nicht mehr leisten können in deutschland
und es ist ja im moment sogar die
absurde situation dass der ja noch
verdient an seinem krieg weil die
gaspreise weiter steigen und russland
eben einer der größten gasexporteur ist
und dass das kann es ja nicht sein das
müssen wir beenden deswegen also
mindestens müssen wir nord stream 1
abschaffen damit er zumindest auch
gezwungen ist das gas noch weiter durch
osteuropa zu leiten und so schnell wie
möglich müssen wir ganz weg kommen vom
russischen gas das ist ein ganz
entscheidender punkt jetzt putin
verstehe ist ein gutes stichwort ich
würde gerne an herr molten mich wenden
erneuten es gibt ja in deutschland und
vor allem auch in ihrer früheren partei
der afd ja auch nach wie vor menschen
die eigentlich putin verherrlichen wie
gefährlich ist das für unsere demokratie
ja ich halte das für hoch gefährlich
aber lassen so dass er mit der
ehemaligen vertrag ist eine ehemalige
also ich spreche für mich und ich keine
lange teilt minuten hat bin glaube ich
dessen unverdächtig eine verherrlichung
von putin zu machen ich würde partiell
widersprechen das ist immer krieg wenn
man versucht andere zu verstehen und
putin zu verstehen finde ich nicht
schlimm verständnis dafür zu haben das
ist das was indiskutabel ist wir müssen
die abläufe verstehen das problem ist
dass man ihm keinesfalls das was er
getan hat irgendeine form von
verständnis entgegenbringen kann denn
was er da macht ist etwas was globale
auswirkungen haben kann das schlimmste
das schlimmste ist die botschaft für
alle skrupellosen machthaber dieser welt
dass krieg zum zweck territoriale
ausdehnung wieder als mögliches mittel
der politik betrachtet wird und erste
nachahmer
melden bereits ihre ansprüche an und das
ist etwas fatales damit endet eine ära
des relativen friedens und auch eine
einer friedens gesinnung und das ist das
was mir besondere sorge macht bei der
ganzen trotzdem hier an dieser stelle
noch einmal nachhaken weil ich ist so
gefährlich auf unser land finde sie sind
sie stehen natürlich für sich selbst und
ich akzeptiere ist auch sehr ist sie
ausgetreten sind aber wie stark ist die
afd denn für mein eigenes verständnis
unterwandert auch mit putin verstehen
und wie gefährlich ist dass man ist ja
gewöhnt dass dort auch nazis aber jetzt
auch noch menschen die eigentlich ja was
putin tun in ordnung finden fast stand
verherrlichen ja sie halten sie bringen
als spinnereien auf dem ich eigentlich
gar nicht einsteigen will weil noch
einmal das ist nicht meine partei ich
habe eine entscheidung getroffen die hat
übrigens auch damit zu tun und damit
mache ich mir das auch nicht mehr zu
eigen und bremsen werden wir auf granit
beißen ich äußere mich zu fd nicht mehr
den ort darf ich mal kurz also ich meine
das ist ja der klassische trick den wir
leider gewöhnt sind sowohl in ihrem
widerspruch ich hab ja ganz bewusst so
genannte pudding verstehe er gesagt weil
man jetzt damit zu sämtlichen feinheiten
auf die sich dann kapriziert würde es
geht natürlich darum dass leute ganz
stark auch aus der afc und eben auch in
der zeit als sie deren sprecher waren
verständnis geäußert haben für wladimir
putin schlimmer noch die afg an einem
bundestagsabgeordneten von dem putin
gesagt hat er stehe unter oder russland
stehe unter vollständiger kontrolle des
kreml ja es gibt in landtagsabgeordneten
hier in berlin der gesagt hat der putin
eisingen freund bezeichnet hat und so
weiter es gibt viele derartige beispiele
und das ist natürlich in der zeit
passiert in der sie sprecher waren so
dass wenn dieser trend ist eine wenn ich
eine sache kurz sagen darf na ja
also bitte ermorden ich habe jetzt
einfach mal ja ich habe nebenbei einfach
mal mir angeschaut was sie zur
wiederwahl von wladimir putin gesagt
haben wenn ich das mal vorlesen darf
zitat wir gratulieren wladimir putin zu
seiner wiederwahl zum russischen
staatspräsidenten wir wünschen ihm viel
erfolg und politische um sich für seine
nächste amtsperiode
die ard wird sich nach wie vor für einen
dialog mit russland auf augenhöhe
ansetzen und alles daran setzen dass die
deutsch russischen beziehungen zu einer
konstruktiven normalität zurückkehren
dazu gehört auch die für beide seiten
schädlichen sanktionen abzubauen und
jetzt hören sie doch mal auf davon zu
reden dass das ihre ex partei ist das
haben sie gesagt das ist doch ihre
meinung hören sie doch auf sich jetzt
von der afg dazu entfernt sie waren hat
putin freuen und jetzt tun sie so als
wären sie das nicht mehr herunter als
parteivorsitzender gratuliert man
menschen die gewählt wurden wurden in
relevanten nationen das tue ich auch
dass selbstverständlichkeit habe ich
gemacht so untersagen dass man die
sanktionen der savanne auge dass man da
sagt man auch dass man die sanktionen
nicht mehr möchte in einer situation wo
bereits klar war dass wladimir putin der
aggressor ist wladimir putin ganz klar
die ukraine einen krieg geführt hat
bereits erneuten ich habe diesen krieg
hier seit acht jahren erlebt im osten
ist ging nicht allein erst losfährt es
war schon im osten seit jahren extra sie
haben sich dafür eingesetzt hat dass die
sanktionen nicht mehr stattfinden
sollten hören sie doch mal auf
die show führen sich ganz heftig aber
lassen sie mich bitte auch ausreden wenn
ich sage dass es sinnvoll ist in einem
konstruktiven dialog zwischen nationen
zu sein dann ist das sinnvoll sie haben
sich dafür ausgesprochen dass die
sanktionen abgeschafft werden soll
wollen doch was haben die sanktionen
denn gebracht was haben sie gebracht in
welcher situation sind wir heute denken
sie da die sagen was wir waren nicht
scharf genug diese aktion war nicht
scharf genug und deswegen konnte putin
das überhaupt tun was er hier tut
erneuten sie sind mit ihrer politik
mitverantwortlich mit ihrem relativismus
dass die situation so ist wie sie gerade
ist also dass das ist wirklich eine
absurdität nicht zu überbieten lieber
herr uns einmal in aller deutlichkeit
ist ist nicht zu überbieten es ist
quatsch was sie da sagen erklärte das
doch mal
noch einmal es ist sinnvoll einen dialog
zu suchen es ist auch sinnvoll für
europäer mit russland dialog zu suchen
das sollte man tun da sollte man
übrigens aber dann erklären sie doch
einmal warum sie die sanktionen
abschaffen wollten zu diesem zeitpunkt
bereits weil sie keinen zweck hatten um
in den dialog zurückzufinden der wenn er
stattgefunden hätte die situation heute
vielleicht etwas anders darstellte als
sie sich heute darstellt was wir doch
erleben ist ein scheitern des westens
auf der ganzen linie
das ist einfach so und der mann und
deswegen haben sie auch deswegen haben
sie auch wahlbeobachter nach russland
geschickt auf die krim geschickt
deswegen haben sie mit putin gekuschelt
über all die jahre ich halte ich will
musik jordan meine frühere nicht alleine
wurde so ein beobachter der konzern hat
sicher solche wenn sie wenn sie wenn sie
wenn sie sich dafür aussprechen dass die
sanktion abgeschafft werden doch in
einer gezeigt in der putin bereits krieg
geführt es geht um sanktionen in einer
zeit wo wladimir putin bereits krieg in
der ost ukraine geführt und sie haben
sich dafür ausgesprochen dass diese
sanktion abgeschafft werden soll sie
haben wahlbeobachter hingeschickt und
haben sich von der propaganda von
wladimir putin einnehmen lassen und sie
waren damals als parteivorsitzender
dafür verantwortlich und jetzt können
sie nicht sagen nein da habe ich gar
nichts mit zu tun dass meine frühere
partei sie waren parteivorsitzender
herrnsheimer dann müssten wir über das
reden was in diesen acht jahren im don
was passiert ist das nur separate
geschichte ich bin ein zweiter fernseher
gerne davon ausgegangen dass wir in
dieser sendung über die aktuelle
situation sprechen und in der aktuellen
situation sage ich ihnen die aktuelle
situation hat sehr viel damit dass sie
außerdem welche politik in deutschland
passiert ist ich lasse sie gerne aus
aber erregung wäre was erzählen aber man
muss sich aber muss sich auch ausreden
lassen auch gerne ehre von ihnen
ermorden ich brauche keine ehre was ich
ihnen das fenster also geht man nicht
miteinander um ich verstehe ihre ihre
hohe erregung und ich verstehe dass sie
dass sie dann sehr sehr schweren job
derzeit verrichten aber deswegen kann
man dass man hier mit meinen sie nicht
auch verlag berlin auch wenn nicht in
berlin sitzen würde vermuten würde ich
ihnen das genauso ins gesicht sagen sehe
ich weiter situationen hin zu den
situationen die wir heute haben ist nun
auf meine ex parteien und wirklich
zurückzuführen denn die wir niemals in
irgendeiner regierungsverantwortung so
die situation haben wir und das sind
viele fehler gemacht
es wurden fundamentale fehler auf
russischer seite gemacht worden das sind
fundamentale fehler auf seiten des
westens gemacht worden man hat den kurs
des dialoges verlassen und das war ein
fehler und den können wir jetzt
durchdeklinieren ich glaube nur dass in
einer situation wie der jetzigen wir
besser uns die zeit damit
oder die zeit besser damit verbinden
dass wir uns fragen was ist denn jetzt
zu tun als eine analyse der vergangenen
acht jahre die hilf uns wenn ich in der
jetzigen situation kein bisschen weiter
für welche sanktionen sind sie denn
jetzt erneuten wenn wir jetzt in der iss
zeit sind wofür sind sie jetzt ich halte
die aktuellen sanktionen die von der
bundesregierung ergriffen wurden für
notwendig und richtig
ich habe keine großen illusionen dass
sie eine
veränderung der situation im kreml
hervorrufen werden aber was wäre die
alternative die alternative wäre nichts
zu tun und nichts zu tun das können wir
uns in der situation nicht leisten denn
das ist genau das fatale signal dass wir
dann an die aggressoren der welt
schicken also müssen wir sagen wir
müssen etwas tun wenn wir nicht
militärisch eingreifen dann in der tat
kommt morgen die sanktionen nicht herum
die sanktionen geht sind sehr
weitreichend und zuversicht ich kommen
wir zu ihnen sie hatten jetzt noch gar
keiner zeit etwas zu sagen was ist es
was glauben sie die sanktionen welche
wie wie können wieder stoppen wie können
wir diesen widerlichen ich möchte auch
einfach mal sagen aggressor putin
stoppen also ich glaube dass das
scheitern und das hat er uns er
unterstrich das scheitern lag darin dass
nach 2014 nach den tabubrüchen der
annexion der krim eines brutalen krieges
im dom was dem eingreifen von russland
2015 in syrien die unterstützung für
eine politik von assad die genau das
vorgezeichnet hat was wir heute sehen
also die erhebung von aleppo durch
bombardierungen durch vertreibung der
bevölkerung eine verbrannte erde und
dann das entvölkerte territorium
zurückholen auf all diese aggressionen
hat der gesamte westen hat deutschland
haben aber auch viele andere europäische
länder nicht reagiert und das bedeutete
dass bis drei wochen bis vor drei wochen
bis kurz vor dem krieg wladimir putin
jede menge gründe hatte zu erwarten dass
auch diesmal keine sanktionen folgen
also die abschreckung hat dieses mal vor
allem deswegen nicht geklappt weil bis
vor wenigen wochen ein viktor orban nach
moskau gereist ist und in der presse
gesagt hat ungarn ist gegen sanktionen
in der österreichischen politik gesagt
wurde vom aus minister und anderen nord
stream 2 steht nicht zur debatte in
italien von premierminister mario draghi
gesagt wurde also sanktionen bringen gar
nicht europa hat keinen einfluss und
diese kombination natürlich die deutsche
debatte haben wir alle verfolgt wie
schwierig es war
neben den putin freundin da fd und den
putin freunden in der linkspartei auch
für parteien der mitte sich hier klar zu
positionieren und das hat den eindruck
und er war fatal hinterlassen putin kann
diese kriege weiterführen er wird keinen
preis bezahlen der westen wird sich
wieder mit ihm arrangieren und als sich
2015 mosca war für einige zeit da waren
war die überraschung wie viel meiner
gesprächspartner gerade auch leute die
dem kreml nahe standen
warum haben die deutschen überhaupt
sanktionen überhaupt die schwachen
sanktionen dies nach 2015 gab wir haben
erwartet mit den deutschen macht man
geschäfte die beteiligen sich nicht das
ist etwas amerikanisches und ich glaube
das war der fatale fehler und wenn wir
etwas lernen müssen dann dass das
komplett ignorieren von jeglicher form
von moral in der außenpolitik am ende
auch nicht gut fürs geschäft ist denn
jetzt stehen all diese firmen ob total
die großen energiefirmen alle die die in
russland investieren haben stehen jetzt
vor den scherben ihrer politik denn
natürlich brauchen wir einen rahmen ein
internationales system und das blau die
mir putin dieses system zerstören wollte
das ist schon seit über einem jahrzehnt
eigentlich offensichtlich aber er konnte
in der illusion weiter agieren das eben
der westen auch deutschland auch die eu
das durchgehen lässt
ich denke das ist ein gutes alle kraters
schlusswort für die erste debatte es
geht weiter mit dem thema was uns heute
hier morgen mitgebracht hat
ja
ich habe mit gebracht
ein zitat des chinesischen
außenministers yang li das mich sehr
beschäftigt ist das nur im wortlaut vor
damit ich nicht falsch zitieren china
und russland sind füreinander die
wichtigsten geografischen nachbarn sagt
er und strategischen partner die
beziehung der beiden völker ist
felsenfest und folgt der logik der
geschichte china und russland wären
ihren werden ihren fokus nicht aus den
augen verlieren wir bilden eine
partnerschaft zur koordinierung einer
neuen ära
und genau darum geht es hier natürlich
ganz ganz maßgeblich putin könnte das
gar nicht machen ohne chinesische
rückendeckung und es ist eine frage des
hegemonial strebens ist bedauerlich dass
es dass nach wie vor so gibt aber was
mich umtreibt ist der eindruck dass die
hegemonie des alten westens unter
führung der usa
vorübergeht vielleicht ist sie bereits
vorüber gegangen mit dem 24 toten
russland agiert nicht alleine russland
agiert mit voller unterstützung chinas
und dass dieser eingriff es jetzt
erfolgte hat mit den olympischen spielen
in beijing zu tun wenn die nicht gewesen
wären wäre der mensch ein ich früher
erfolgt und dass etwas das mir große
sorge macht weil ich nicht unter einer
hegemonialmacht china und auch nicht
russland nehmen möchte
also ich glaube dass
uns diese krise eben auch gezeigt hat
dass in dieser welt in der autoritäre
staaten zu kooperieren sich den rücken
stärken auch bei ihrer aggressiven
außenpolitik ihren ansprüchen
unterstützen das in dieser welt
organisationen eben wie die europäische
union die in den letzten jahren sehr oft
sehr naiv agiert hat sich die aber in
dieser krise jetzt zum ersten mal seit
langem wieder entdeckt was für eine
existenzielle sicherheit dadurch
entsteht dass die beiden eben nicht
alleine sind dass polen eben nicht
alleine ist dass die europäer bei
sanktionen als wirtschaftsmacht ein land
wie russland auch wirklich treffen
können wir erkennen jetzt dass diese
europäische union und der alte westen wo
wir glück haben das jetzt nicht donald
trump im weißen haus sitzt in dieser
krise ein rückgrat sind dafür dass das
europa die demokratie die menschenrechte
die freiheit die wir als gegeben genau
hin genommen haben vereinigt werden
können also ich glaube was wir jetzt
auch erkennen ist wie gefährliches war
in den letzten jahren und wladimir putin
hat ja auch hinein investiert
er hat ja parteien und politiker
unterstützt die anti europäisch die für
den austritt aus der europäischen union
waren wie frau le pen in frankreich bei
den letzten wahlen die wie matteo
salvini die europäische union als ein
neues imperium angegriffen haben matteo
salvini war vor wenigen der beliebteste
politiker italiens und sagt er fühlt
sich im kreml wohl und nicht in brüssel
diese diese politik putins das zu
schwächen was uns jetzt in der krise
letztlich vor noch mehr ungeschützt wo
wir jetzt unsere verteidigung stärken
müssen wir müssen die europäische union
auch die beistands verpflichtungen die
sich aus dem eu vertrag ergeben das muss
substanz annehmen dass wir nicht auf
alle ewigkeiten vollkommen abhängig
bleiben von der frage wen wählen die
amerikaner aber ich glaube genau das vor
dem bild das sie skizzieren mit
autoritären herausforderern die
aggressiv sind ist der zusammenhalt des
westens die institutionen die wir haben
umso wichtiger und ich glaube das wird
jetzt hoffentlich auch in deutschland
weit über die das einfach für gegeben
hin da sehen sie dass putin sich sich
geirrt hat putin dann nämlich könnte das
alles weiter spalten und auseinander
treiben und das exakte gegenteil ist
eingetroffen also ich arbeite ich wusste
ich erlebt dass jeden tag die eu steht
in diesen tagen seit kriegsbeginn so
geschlossen wie ich sie nicht erlebt
habe seit seit ich dort arbeite und das
immerhin ist ein hoffnungszeichen nicht
viel mehr als das weil wenn sie den
vertreter der europäischen union als
gesprächspartner nehmen dann agiert er
bis heute nicht auf augenhöhe
das sind die amerikaner und die russen
eventuell noch immer kommen aber
sicherlich hierher nicht der boris
herrmann oft sind von mir gehört pauli
also ich ertrage ich ertrage das einfach
nicht wenn er morgen über die
geschlossenheit der europäischen union
spricht er tut so als wären sie ermorden
für eine geschlossenheit der
europäischen union noch einmal
sie haben die sanktionen hintertrieben
sie haben gesagt die sanktionen müssen
in einer zeit in der wladimir putin
bereits hier frauen und kinder
umgebracht hat indem er den dom bars mit
waffen ausgestattet hat mit kämpfern
ausgestattet hat indem er diese menschen
motiviert hat und auch russische kämpfer
rhein geschickt hat die ukraine
anzugreifen das war der anfang dieses
krieges der gerade hier wo ich bin
stattfindet und sie haben gesagt diese
sanktion müssen aufhören und jetzt reden
sie allen ernstes über eine
geschlossenheit der europäischen union
die sie gut finden wo sie immer gegen
diese geschlossenheit agiert haben und
sie haben als ard vorsitzender und als
der erneuten als der sitzen sonst werden
sie doch gar nicht in irgend einer tv
show noch wenn sie nicht ab vorsitzender
gewesen wären also entschuldigen sie
bitte mal das geld das kriegen sie auch
nicht aber das kriege ich auch nicht
runter da sind sie so und in dieser
funktion waren sie im europaparlament
und da haben sie in verschiedenen in
ganz vielen verschiedenen funktionen
gesagt diese sanktionen sind falsch und
sie haben dafür gesorgt dass diese
europäische union gespalten ist dass
europa gespalten werden konnte das war
der anfang des endes der ukraine und das
haben sie mit zu verantworten nein nein
bei uns aber ich muss das wirklich
wirklich zurückweisen das ging und geht
auch jetzt noch darum dass man in einen
konstruktiven dialog hinein findet und
das geht nicht auf dem weg der vom
besten beschritten wurde im übrigen hat
war ich immer ein
kritiker der viele politikfelder die in
brüssel falsch angesiedelt sind ich habe
aber immer ein ausdrückliches bekenntnis
zur europäischen union am tag gelegt das
war für mich übrigens einer der
zentralen gründe aber gegen diesen
regionen und die europäische union das
ist doch eher erneuten sie waren als ab
davor sitzen ich kann ihn jetzt mehrere
mitteilungen vorlesen in sehen sie sich
dafür ausgesprochen haben dass die
sanktionen beendet werden und jetzt tun
sie so als wären sie für die sanktion
das ist so eine glatte lügen ein stop
stop flüge lass ich mich nicht sein ich
habe gesagt jetzigen sanktionen halte
ich für richtig die sanktionen die wir
vorher hatten habe ich für falsch
gehalten hätte ich auf dialog gesetzt in
der jetzigen situation der krieg im
osten war nicht so schlimm oder
wasserwege boston war nicht so schlimm
im don was wenn da frauen und kinder
gestorben sind da haben sie gesagt das
ist nicht so schlimm hat es im tief da
muss es sanktionen geben herunter man
sie haben eine sehr eigentümliche sicht
auf die ereignisse im don was das müsste
man in einer liga habe ich eigentlich
langsam habe ich nicht nur sie ein recht
durchsichtiger diese lernten die sendung
ist lang genug ermorden die sendung ist
lang genug um um zu entlarven irgendwo
werden
aber ich bin ganz christian ganz kurz ja
heißt hereinholen der hatte bislang die
wenigsten jede zeit mehr als alles gut
also ich finde das ja an interessanten
und auch einen wertvollen dialog 2 oder
uns haben wir ja wirklich schön dass
auch mal auf zeigt wieder agiert wird
mit halbwahrheiten und herunter man hat
ja zum glück wirklich die redaktion
kenntnis vor ort um das auch widerlegen
zu können und es ist natürlich der punkt
den herr klaus auch zurecht angesprochen
hat es ist diese naivität die auch zu
lange bei uns im westen noch
vorgeherrscht hat und man merkt ja auch
nach wie vor also ich hab das erwähnt
wenn die alv den bundestagsabgeordneten
hat wo der kreml sinngemäß sagt den
haben wir der tasche aber leider erleben
dass auch bei der linkspartei wo eine
führende außenpolitikerin sagt also der
der ukrainische botschafter in
deutschland sei ein hetzer vor dem herrn
ja nicht etwa putin das ist so eine art
fünfte kolonne der autokraten sagen
sollte eigentlich die ganzen politiker
macht die wfg und weise wie wir uns zu
sagen von merkel steinmeier morgen ihre
helligkeit ist wirklich nicht zu
überbieten sie geben jetzt hier den
geläuterten weil sie auch märkte
gekommen ronzheimer sonst nicht weiter
ich hätte mir selber noch davon
gesprochen dass es vorher kräftig
verlassen was ja das ist ja richtig aber
es ist habe diese parasiten reagiert
haben wurde heute noch gesagt es ist
also barer putin gemacht hätte fehler
waren sind dass dort fehlt mir noch
semantische ungenauigkeit sie habe
fehler und er hat kriegsverbrecher in
syrien unterstützt der hat
völkerrechtswidrig land in europa wieder
anschläge ist jugendlich hieß er hat
gute geführt sondern das sind
irgendwelche fehler das sind
kriegsverbrechen zum teil ja und das ist
genau diese diese perfide verharmlosung
in den formulierungen die erleben wenn
sie frau verschenkt ist bin vorgeworfen
habe das war kein spin das hat er uns
haben uns soeben erklärt das war ihnen
die wahrheit und deswegen also sollten
wir und sorgen für gesunde abgehen eine
ganz kurze unterbrechung kühlen ganz
kurz alle ein wenig ab und sind dann
gleich wieder zurück mit der analyse von
putins krieg bis gleich
[Musik]
wir sind zurück ging es gerade schon
hoch her ich bin mir sicher ist mit
weiter hoch her gehen hier mit
leidenschaftlich debattiert und auch
gestritten das ist gut so heute abend
die gäste jörg philipp heiß nach und
auch mit dabei natürlich pforzheimer und
gereiht hinaus und jetzt legen wir los
mit dem thema von herrn aus und zwar ist
es wie heißt wird der kalte krieg
also ich glaube was wir jetzt erlebt
haben und was viele ja fast alle
europäer schockiert ist wie fragil
dieses europa ist auch dass wir uns
verlassen haben also ein europa in dem
einfach krieg bürgerkrieg politische
gefangene erfolgter nicht mehr denkbar
seien sollten erlebt dass autokraten
ohne gruppe europäische große städte wie
kiew bombardieren und die frage ist
jetzt reagieren wir darauf mit den
richtigen schlüssel
lernen wir wie wir unsere institutionen
besser verteidigen können gegen
korruption dagegen dass spitzenpolitiker
aus europa von putin und anderen
autokraten kurz nach amtsantritt
angestellt und bezahlt werden wie
reagieren wir darauf dass institutionen
wie der europarat unterwandert wurden
von russland erpresst wurden und immer
klein beigegeben haben wie reagieren wir
darauf dass wir in unseren parlamenten
parteien haben die sich putin angedient
haben auch oft im prominenten positionen
wie in italien oder frankreich
ich glaube wir müssen erkennen dass wir
diesen kampf der werte
ernsthaft führen müssen und dass das
argument der jetzt geht es noch geschäft
und die werte sind uns egal dass das am
ende nicht nur für unsere werte unsere
institutionen unsere sicherheit sondern
auch für die wirtschaft eine katastrophe
war und ich hoffe wir lernen diese
lehren und wir reagieren jetzt richtig
denn wenn wir das nicht tun dann ist die
gefahr dass putin diesen krieg den er
uns erklärt hat am ende auch noch
gewinnen kann weil er unsere im kern
erschüttert und unsere institutionen
fatale schwäche weil du bist vor ort wie
reagieren wir jetzt richtig deine
forderung an die deutsche politik
ich glaube dass wir durchaus auf einem
richtigen weg sind ich glaube dass es
noch schärfere sanktionen bräuchte das
ist weitere waffenlieferungen bräuchte
uns vor allem sozusagen
flugabwehrraketen abwehrmöglichkeiten
für die ukraine denn das ist das was
hier droht
gleichzeitig habe ich das gefühl dass
deutschland zumindest für die ukraine
keine wirklich große rolle momentan mehr
spielt wenn man sehr enttäuscht ist von
der regierung weil man sehr enttäuscht
darüber das ist am anfang sozusagen die
ukraine gar nicht ernst genommen wurde
dass man gesagt hat ja ach also in
russland habt ihr keine chance deswegen
geben wir euch keine waffen machts halt
alleine und dann gesagt hat ja aufgrund
unserer geschichte können wir das
natürlich nicht tun um ihr ukraine
gesagt haben moment mal auf teure
geschichte müsste dir es doch gerade tun
ja also das ist das eine das zweite ist
und das gehört natürlich zur wahrheit
dazu und das ist auch das was ich hier
erlebe in den vergangenen stunden und in
den vergangenen tagen die frage wie
schafft man frieden weil das ist ja das
was alle leute sagen würden sofort wir
wollen nicht mehr tote wir wollen nicht
mehr kinder die sterben wir wollen nicht
mehr frauen die sterben wir wollen wir
wollen frieden in unserem land
und die ukraine ist glaube ich
tatsächlich zu vielen bereit aber wenn
wladimir putin bei dem bleibt was er
gesagt hat zu beginn des krieges nämlich
der ukraine die existenzberechtigung
abspricht
was soll ein land tun was würde
deutschland tun wenn ein großes land
kämen und sage deutschland gibt es
eigentlich gar nicht die gehören zu uns
halten ist die kann man dann sagen
alles noch etwas ergänzen
am morgen ist die ukraine zu recht
enttäuscht von deutschland
ich kann die enttäuschung verstehen weil
ich glaube mussten empathie für die
situation haben ihn der die menschen
dort sind auch der präsident selbst
und von daher kann ich das sehr gut
verstehen die frage ist aber wenn der
realpolitik machen was ist sinnvoll zu
tun was nicht und es gibt ja drei
möglichkeiten nichts zu tun und ich
glaube das wäre wirklich völlig
unverantwortlich oder mit sanktionen auf
dieses verbrechen zu antworten das tun
wir oder militärisch einzugreifen
ein militärisches eingreifen ich glaube
das ist jedem hier bewusst würde die
gefahr einer gewaltigen eskalation in
sich bergen infolgedessen ist das was
deutschland jetzt tut auch was die
europäische union jetzt tut nämlich mit
sanktionen zu antworten auch wenn das
vielleicht nicht so wirksam ist wie wir
uns das wünschen würden das mittel der
wahl und wir können nicht jeden wunsch
von präsident see lenski erfüllen auch
wenn man ihn emotional völlig verstehen
kann man muss sich die verzweifelte
situation der menschen dort bewusst
machen ronzheimer es glaube ich auch
deswegen so emotional auch das gar nicht
verstehen weil er das live miterlebt und
dann hat man eine spezielle sicht auf
die dinge das ist einfach so wenn man
wenn man das fürchterliche geschehen
dort hautnah miterlebt wenn man
unmittelbar betroffen ist dass man sagt
helft uns militärisch geht da rein
aber ich wäre definitiv gegen ein
militärisches ein sicher nicht immer
unterbrechen das finde ich sehr
freundlich
ja das finde ich nicht mehr gesehen
also ein militärisches eingreifen würde
ich für falsch halten und für ungemein
gefährlich halten nichtstun geht nicht
die sanktion auch in der härte halte ich
für angezeigt und richtig pauli jetzt
unterbricht die ja nicht aber ich lass
dich darauf antwort nachdem schon
erklärt wurde wie du dich so verhält und
warum
ja ich glaube dass diese analyse zu
sagen weil jemand dinge sieht hat eine
besondere emotionalität die trifft
vielleicht zu aber ich kann sagen für
mich oder für bild wir haben da
eigentlich
2013/2014 eine sehr klare sicht auf
die dinge die hier passieren
ja ich habe gesehen wie auf der krim die
annexion passiert ist wie damals
schuldigen sie bitte aber die kfd das
mehr oder weniger bejubelt hat was dort
passierte und in dombach und gesagt hat
na ja das gehört ja schon irgendwie zu
russland
und ich habe danach gesehen was in
diesem krieg passiert ist und ich habe
gesehen was menschen passiert ist die
neben gestanden die gestorben sind und
ich habe gesehen
wie putin dieses land auslöschen wollte
und will und dafür muss man glaube ich
gar nicht hier sein wo ich gerade bin in
kiew dafür kann man auch sehr nüchtern
und sicherlich vielleicht nicht so
emotional wie ich gerade über die dinge
nachdenken und den lesen und analysieren
und dann kommt man zu der genau gleichen
erkenntnis dass das was vladimir putin
tut sehr sehr viele jahre klar war und
viele politiker wie sie haben und auch
andere politiker das nicht sehen wollen
dass das so kommen würde und mir jetzt
eine besondere emotionalität zu
unterstellen weil ich hier bin geschenkt
aber ich kann ihnen sagen noch einmal
wenn ich jetzt dort im studio wo ich ja
auch schon ein paar mal sah sitzen würde
würde ich ihnen das genauso sagen ich
finde auch ein ganz wichtiger aspekt um
vielleicht also ich kann emotionalität
auch nachvollziehen ich wollte noch mal
einen aspekt betonen ausgesagt hat die
bedeutung von bündnissen das ist ja auch
etwas was wir gestreift haben aber die
bedeutung der europäischen union auch
wenn sie nicht perfekt sein mag und die
bedeutung der nato ist glaube ich fielen
in den letzten wochen noch mal sehr sehr
klar geworden die sie vorher nicht so
hatten also wir haben ja jahrelang dafür
gekämpft dass zwei prozent ziel der nato
zum beispiel einzuhalten und das stieß
auf widerstand gegen waffenlieferungen
und vielleicht ist das auch ein punkt
der uns ein bisschen optimistisch
tatsächlich jetzt mit blick auf die
zukunft machen kann bei allen kolossalen
fehler in seiner vergangenheit ohne
zweifel passiert sind ende deutliche
mehrheit war immer gegen
waffenlieferungen jetzt ist eine
deutliche mehrheit dafür plötzlich ist
die spd dafür selbst jusos ich war
letztens auf einer solidaritäts demo mit
für die ukraine zusammen mit jusos die
hinter dem schild dann auch liefen wir
brauchen mehr waffenlieferungen also das
wäre vorher undenkbar gewesen insoferne
gewisser wandel findet schon statt er
ist natürlich viel zu spät und sie haben
ja gefragt wie fühlen sich die ukraine
und das ist natürlich auch eine
emotionale und eine frage der empathie
manchmal wenn ich heute lese dass also
auf von ukrainischer seite der eindruck
entstand ist beim gespräch von präsident
selensky mit olaf scholz hätte die
ukrainische seite mit einer wand geredet
dann ist das eine ganz fatale eindruck
und nicht das signal was wir senden
sollten
ich glaube auch dass
extrem wichtig ist dass die deutsche
politik sich korrigiert das stimmt das
muss aber überall in europa passieren
also wir kommen fokussieren uns
natürlich jetzt hier aber ich habe die
italienische debatte verfolgt dort waren
von berlusconi bis zur salvini eine
ganze reihe von
regierungschefs extrem putin freundlich
haben mit dem urlaub gemacht haben ihn
verehrt haben gelobt
aber eben nicht aus irgendeinem
emotionalen effekt heraus sondern aus
der kühlen erkenntnisse die wir jetzt
gezogen haben putin und diese art von
regime sind eine gefahr für unsere
eigene sicherheit das was in der ukraine
passiert ist wir hätten es als warnung
sehen müssen auch für unsere sicherheit
denn die deutsche sicherheit der
wohlstand die garantien die wir hatten
dass wir eben nicht nachdenken mussten
und ich verstehe dass es viele die
vielleicht auch nach ich die nächste
generation die nach dem balkan kriegen
groß geworden ist die hat keine kriege
in europa erlebt die konnte sich das
nicht vorstellen dass man militär
braucht das man robuste wehrhafte
institutionen braucht aber dass dieser
ihr dieser irrtum sollte jetzt
ausgeräumt sein wir sehen
ein wladimir putin und das war
eigentlich schon vor vielen jahren klar
ich war 2009 in moskau unter waren
intellektuelle rund um den kreml die das
vorgezeichnet haben was was jetzt
passiert die haben auch damals schon
gesagt wir wir akzeptieren den vormarsch
der nato nicht das war natürlich eine
ausrede die idee die ukraine hat 2014
ein assoziierungsabkommen mit der eu
abschließen wollen für ihren wohlstand
weil sie gesehen hat was das bewirkt hat
in polen und rumänien
dem europäischen markt anzugehören das
wollten sie und das hat
zudem versucht zu stoppen also es ging
da nie wirklich um die nato es ging auch
nicht um russisches sicherheit das war
alles vorgeschoben das problem war es
gab zu viele quer durch alle politischen
lager in vielen europäischen ländern die
dann diese russischen argumente putins
argumente denn es gab in russland immer
wieder stand und man muss auch daran
erinnern die vielen mutigen russen die
uns gewarnt haben wo sind sie heute ein
beuys nimmt so wurde in der nähe des
kremls erschossen andere
kasparow ist jetzt im exil viele sind im
gefängnis naja weil ja der sich immer
der immer gewarnt hat vor putins gefahr
nicht nur für russen und russinnen
sondern für europa ruft jetzt vom
gefängnis aber was für ein nudist das
vom gefängnis auch darf dazu auf zu
protestieren ich glaube wenn man das
sinken wenn man das versteht wie wie
gefährlich das war dann glaube ich
entsteht auch der konsens ich bin da
auch optimistisch dass wir uns in die
richtung bewegen in deutschland und in
europa dass wir noch weiter gehen müssen
was die sanktionen betrifft dass wir
auch das risiko von wohlstands einbußen
zumindest kurzfristig eingehen müssen
weil wir am ende mehr verlieren wenn
wladimir putin weiterhin davon überzeugt
bleibt der westen ist schwach und
dekadent und kann sich nicht wehren und
ist zerstritten wir müssen zeigen dass
demokratien und demokraten und da ist
bleiben wir da ist wo lenski ein modell
für uns alle und ich glaube deswegen ist
auch so eine ich eine ikone geworden ob
jetzt im europaparlament oder im
englischen house of commons spricht dass
demokratie verteidigt werden muss also
jemand der als schauspieler als als
komiker in die politik kommt der gewählt
werden kann beispiel für die großartige
ukrainische demokratie dass das möglich
ist das waren also umdenken system für
deutschland ich glaube die tatsache dass
regierungen gewählt und abgewählt werden
können ist dass leute aus der neuen die
politik komm her dass jemand nicht wie
www putin
dafür ihr schon gesagt jürgen klopp
sollte bundeskanzler werden bei den
sichteinlagen eine these die komische
ich glaube dass das entscheidende ist
was man jetzt eben selensky hat und die
verteidigte jetzt wurde er hat wertet
ich meine ein beispiel der kontrakt
zürich in moskau was mir aufgefallen ist
die besessenheit in der russischen
führung bei diesen ganzen kreml
intellektuellen gegen gegen lgbt rechte
die angriffe auf pride parade in europa
bevor wir dahin jetzt es wird jetzt
neuer themenkomplex anja und ausland hat
im wahlkampf gesagt wir sind für
toleranz in der in der ukraine und ich
glaube dieser kontrast zwischen der mut
der zwischen werten und pluralismus und
jetzt muss man und das ist das tragische
jetzt müssen die ukraine genau das
nämlich ihr land ihre demokratie ihre
identität mit waffen verteidigen und
dabei ist sollte der westen alles was
verantwortlich verantwortungsvoll
gemacht werden kann inklusive lieferung
von waffen inklusive schärfere
sanktionen machen denn was hier im spiel
stets in unsere werte ein grund warum
deutschland ja vielleicht ab und an doch
auch etwas zaghaft handelt ist ja auch
die putin abhängigkeit und darüber
möchten sie heute sprechen heißt ja wir
haben ja eben darüber gesprochen dass es
ganz enorm wichtig ist jetzt vom
russischen gas wegzukommen von der
abhängigkeit vom russischen gas und da
müssen wir einfach die realität
anerkennen und da muss auch die
bundesregierung und insbesondere die
grünen weg kommen von ihrer
ideologischen fundamental verweigerung
gegenüber der kernenergie wir haben wir
erleben in allen ländern um uns herum in
polen in den niederlanden in frankreich
oder großbritannien das neue
kernkraftwerke gebaut werden in schweden
oder italien wird der ausstieg aus dem
ausstieg diskutiert deutschland ist in
der frage der kernkraft inzwischen der
geisterfahrer in europa der glaubt alle
anderen würden in die falsche richtung
fahren und deswegen ist es jetzt an der
zeit im übrigen auch angesichts der
zweiten großen krise die wir haben und
das ist der klimawandel wir müssen den
co2 ausstoß weiter verringern wir
brauchen mehr elektrizität etwa für
elektroautos und das zusammenzubringen
das geht eben am ende technisch nur mit
der kenntnis ja wir müssen auch die
erneuerbaren energien weiter ausbauen
aber diese unabhängigkeit ist ganz ganz
wichtig und im übrigen wies auch das
argument von vblock dagegen überhaupt
nicht tragfähig dass sie sagt auch bei
den urahn lieferungen werden wir von
russland abhängig denn zweitgrößter uran
experte der welt ist kanada es gibt ich
glaube auf platz zehn oder sowas selbst
in deutschland gibt es dann vorkommen
also dieses argument trägt nicht die
bundesregierung insbesondere die grünen
müssen weg von ihrem anti kernkraft
dogma damit wir unabhängig werden können
von russischem gas
würden sie dazu sagen ja es wird herrn
heißt nach vielleicht überraschen aber
ich gebe ihnen da vollständig recht
es ist eine forderung die ich selber
seit langem erhebe ich beschäftige mich
mit energiepolitik tiefer der
kardinalfehler der gemacht wurde in
unserer energieversorgung gehen hat
angela merkel 2011 mit dem ausstieg aus
der kernenergie gemacht der überhastet
war der falsch war und der uns in die
abhängigkeit hineingebracht hat die wir
heute mit recht beklagen das ist das
fatale nun haben wir einen kernkraftwerk
nach dem anderen abgeschaltet wir haben
im moment noch drei im netz ich habe in
ihrem statement gelesen sie wollten auch
welche die schon vom netz gegangen sind
wieder ans netz holen das wird nicht
funktionieren das kann ich ihnen sagen
reden wir mit den ingenieuren die sich
darauf verstehen mit den
energieanbietern das geht nicht aber es
ist bedauerlich dass das geschehen ist
grundsätzlich aber ist die position die
sie haben völlig richtig wenn wir eine
unabhängigkeit haben wollen und wir
brauchen grundlastfähigen energie das
liefern wind und solarenergie nicht dann
kommen wir um moderne nutzung der
kernenergie nicht herum und da sind
keine steinzeit reaktoren mehr wie anno
dunnemals sondern die reaktoren der
vierten generation sind sehr sicher und
deswegen sollte man tatsächlich darauf
setzen auf diese technologie nicht
verzichten so dass wir einen
ideologiefreien dass das was sie mit
recht monieren wir haben eine völlig
ideologie geleitete in der
energiepolitik insbesondere betrieben
von grünen wir brauchen eine
ideologiefreie positionierung dazu und
dann werden wir einen energiemix
bekommen in dem die kernenergie und zwar
in moderner form ebenso vorkommt wie wie
selbstverständlich auch erneuerbare
energien
also ich hab das ja auch nicht gesagt
ich sage mal wenn wir über neue
reaktoren reden würden dann würden wir
auch über technische innovationen reden
müssen und das ist ja auch weil
natürlich dass im sinne auch der
nachhaltigkeit das problem der endlager
endlagerung natürlich ein anderes ist
bei modernen reaktoren die er noch dann
sehen ein verbraucher dennoch wieder
verwenden können insofern glaube ich ja
ist das einfach wichtig dass wir damit
kommen ist ist ja insgesamt auch eine
frage der technologieoffenheit ich meine
selbst die fdp ist jetzt ja umgekippt
und hat plötzlich gesagt ja beim auto es
liegen wir uns fest auf die batterie
auch das ist ja glaube ich vorschnell
denn genau das ist nicht die aufgabe von
politikern das zu entscheiden sondern
dafür haben einen freien markt der eben
relativ gut darin ist am ende auch
gewinner auszuwählen und verlierer
auszuwählen und das sollten sich
politiker tun insofern ich würde das
nicht ganz teilen was sie gesagt haben
das war ein anderer kontext ich glaube
schon dass wir jetzt noch mal gucken
müssen und das hat eine neue bedeutung
bekommen wie werden wir unabhängig vom
russischen gas ohne massiv unseren co2
ausstoß etwa mit kohle die ansonsten
eine alternative wäre zu erhöhen ich
glaube da sind wir nicht mehr einer
meinung ich habe gelesen jedenfalls dass
sie dem den menschengemachten
klimawandel nicht für eine realität
halten das sehe ich anders und ich habe
das auch anderes gelesen das ist ganz
ganz wichtig ist das ist ganz ganz
wichtig ist dass das können sie ja
korrigieren aber ich glaube das ist ganz
ganz wichtig ist dass wir eben dieses
ziel auch nicht aus den augen verlieren
und das ausgerechnet jetzt die grünen
ich meine die absurde sache ist ja im
grunde genommen ist keine deutsche
partei für mehr co2 ausstoß in
deutschland verantwortlich als die
grünen mit ihrem jahrzehnte lang ihrer
zähne und unwissenschaftlichen kampf
gegen die kernenergie das ist eine
ironie ein stück weiter geschichte aber
da können wir ja eben dazu lernen und
die finnischen grünen übrigens sehen
dass er anders diese nämlich sehr
pragmatisch und realistisch die begrüßen
ausdrücklich die nutzung der kernenergie
in finnland und auch das betreiben einer
endlagerstätte die haben dann völlig
andere herangehensweise
und tatsächlich ist das grüne als das
was die deutschen grünen uns hier als
grün verkaufen das ist tatsächlich so da
müssen wir uns an dieser stelle nicht
auch in der runde ehrlich machen das
werde natürlich sagen wir sollen zurück
zur atomenergie und so weiter aber
müssen wir nicht auch ganz klar sagen es
ist jetzt nicht von heute auf morgen
möglich dass sowieso wir jetzt gerade
agieren und man muss ja klar sagen wenn
wir jetzt zum beispiel die importe von
öl sofort kappen amerika wird sich schon
auch darüber freuen weil die ölindustrie
ist dort sehr sehr stark steigender
ölpreis ist wird ja dann steigen also
die menschen werden einnahmen haben und
putin kann ja auch weiter nach china
verkaufen wenn der ölpreis seien auch
weiter steigt wird das kompensiert
deswegen meine frage in die runde wie
sollen wir uns denn jetzt gerade
verhalten weil es hört sich natürlich
alles richtig an und wir müssen auch
agieren aber werden wir dann auch alle
mit damit leben wollen und das auch
wirklich dafür tun für die ukraine zum
beispiel sie heißen würden sie dann auch
sagen kein problem 40 der auf strom wenn
die wohnung kälter wird ist mir auch
egal also etwas pathetisch jetzt auf ich
habe letztens den schönen spruch gesehen
spule stadt putin da ist natürlich was
dran aber es ist glaube ich auch naiv zu
glauben mit mit mit individuell
maßnahmen allein würde man zurechtkommen
aber natürlich ist das ein richtiger
maßstab im moment übrigens geht es
erstmal darum die drei noch laufenden
kernreaktoren nicht einfach abzuschalten
die sind die funktionieren ja dass das
klappt ja alles also so aber insofern
ich bin völlig bei herrn klaus natürlich
das was in der ukraine verteidigt wird
ist auch unser europa ist es auch unsere
freiheit es sind auch unsere werte und
deswegen es wird am ende nicht gehen
ohne dass wir auch in irgendeiner form
mindestens wohlstands einbußen hinnehmen
natürlich müssen wir dann darauf achten
durch steuersenkungen gerade es kann
nicht sein dass der staat noch an
steigenden benzinpreise versehen oder
eine wohngeld erhöhung oder was auch
immer es dafür maßnahmen gibt damit hier
niemand unter die räder kommt aber
natürlich es wird am ende wenn wir sagen
wir müssen für unsere werte kämpfen
ansonsten haben wir das problem dass die
ukraine hat womöglich irgendwann auch
hier
so diese realitäten dass wir anerkennen
und und vielleicht noch ein letzter satz
die sind diesen appell an den realismus
den herrn ausgerichtet hat den müssen
wir auch mit blick auf china und
uns zu eigen machen denn das ist ja die
nächste frage und china wird sich genau
ansehen wie geht europa wie geht der
westen mit putin um nachdem er die
ukraine überfallen hat also er heißt da
wird es schon mal für für den frieden
und auch für die ukraine frieren wie
sieht es bei ihnen aus leuten wie weit
würden sie wir werden wir werden opfer
dafür bringen müssen und die werden auch
individuell zu erbringen seien das ist
sicherlich so welche opfer würden sie
selbst bringen
wir bringen im moment bereits opfer in
form der der massiven verteuerung der
preise die wir haben ich habe heute früh
um einen öltank zuhause aufgefüllt ich
habe mit öl beheizt das haus und die
haben ja gesagt dass das doppelt so
teuer wie beim letzten mal so dass geht
betrifft mich das betrifft viele andere
und ich mache mir große sorgen um die
anderen nicht um mich selbst weil das
natürlich eine soziale komponente hat
und es ist tatsächlich so dass wir im
energiesektor eine volle mehrwertsteuer
drauf haben da muss man vielleicht mal
an die frage herangehen als
bundesregierung wenn wirklich menschen
das sind nicht mal sozial schwache das
im ganz normalen familien mit kindern
die können sich das nicht mehr leisten
ich habe mein einkommen ich kann das
kann das bezahlen gefällt mir auch nicht
aber das ist nicht das problem aber wir
hatten kommen in die situation rein wo
menschen familien alte menschen in
ungeheizten wohnungen sitzen und das
wollen wir nicht und das können wir
natürlich auch machen mit einem einfluss
auf die preise denn wenn sie sich die
energiepreise mal anschauen und sie
schauen sich den anteil staatlicher
abgaben daran an also exemplarisch beim
liter beim liter diesel den man tankt
haben wir 70 prozent staatliche abgaben
30 prozent ist der warenwert der staat
hat eine menge machen und wir müssen in
dieser situation denen die das nicht
mitgehen können helfen weil das wirklich
und das sind nicht nur dass sie nicht
nur sozial schwache das sind das sind
ganz normale familien mittelklasse
einkommen die zur arbeit fahren müssen
und das trifft die hart und da müssen
wir ran und wir heißt hier die
bundesregierung die bundesregierung
steht in der verantwortung
zum beispiel mit der mehrwertsteuer
runterzugehen das übrigens auch im
brüsseler problem das muss aus brüssel
nämlich genehmigt werden ich habe das
gerade gestern in einer rede im
europäischen parlament so auch gefordert
wobei wir zum beispiel an die
mineralölsteuer auf jeden fall meine ich
ran können und auch mit der
mehrwertsteuer habe ich jetzt auch schon
wieder das gegenteil also auch das ist
zumindest ein rechtlich ist das
ausländerrecht eigenständig machen kann
aber ich möchte mal sagen ihr seid ja
nicht darum jetzt irgendwie die
staatsausgaben enorm zu erhöhen sondern
es geht einfach darum die mehreinnahmen
die der staat ja hat der deutschland
profitiert von den steigenden
energiepreisen im moment die mindestens
zurückzugeben und insofern glaube ich
ist das unbedingt angezeigt dass wir da
steuersenkungen und ich glaube was was
auch klar ist und das ist sollte
eigentlich auch jenseits der ideologie
steht ist dass der ausbau von
erneuerbarer energie oder ist enormes
potenzial immer noch da dass der nicht
nur für deutschland selbst sondern auch
in der deutschen außenpolitik eine rolle
spielen sollte wo ist das deutsche
konzept das europäische konzept auch in
anderen in der nachbarregion mit
tunesien da gibt es sehr viele ich bin
jetzt wirklich kein experte dafür ich
lese was experten sagen aber da gibt es
viel potenzial für partnerschaft mit
sony nennt mit solarenergie mit der
türkei deren abhängigkeit zu reduzieren
von
gas importiert wird autoritären staaten
was die türkei auch als nato-partner
abhängig macht von problemen wie wir
sehen in dieser jetzigen krise das ist
wichtig ist im schwarzen meer auch
verbündete zu haben wie schaffen wir es
in polen zum beispiel immer noch große
abhängigkeit von von extrem schmutziger
kohle die aus russland importiert wird
also selbst polen das eine sehr starke
aus der geschichte vollkommen nicht nur
verständlich sondern rationale
opposition gegenüber russland immer
hatte und irgendwie hätten mehr auf die
polen hören müssen in dieser frage ist
im energiebereich durch die kohle
importe aus russland abhängig ich glaube
diese idee den klimawandel der real ist
wo wir reagieren müssen weil sonst
kommen ganz andere kosten noch auf uns
zu und und die außenpolitik und das
strategische die unabhängigkeit von
autokratien zusammenzudenken europäisch
und da war das problem natürlich es war
zu bequem die letzten jahre ich meine
ich hätte mich noch vor kurzem der
gaspreise was er war unglaublich niedrig
war es vor einem jahr zwei jahre und der
diskurs war wir bauen da pipelines es
gibt schiefergas wir haben rohstoffe
wäre das ganze wurde es wurde viel geld
gemacht in diesem bereich und jetzt
stellt sich heraus dass sowohl
strategisch als auch natürlich von der
perspektive vor co2 und dem umbau auf
ein klimafreundliches wirtschaftssystem
dass diese bequemlichkeit auch
verteidigt wir kriegen das so
kurzfristig nicht gelöst langfristig ist
das ein weg den man gehen kann aber sie
können mit erneuerbaren jetzt im moment
überhaupt nichts retten sie können sagen
wir bauen das langfristig aus dass ich
habe lange
ein strukturiertes ablegen wo heute die
flaschen
vision die so wichtig ist für unser land
rein drift möchte ich aber noch einmal
heran zimmer ist uns ja weiter in den
ganzen amt live dauerhaft zugeschaltet
wenn du uns hier reden hört über die
spritpreise über energie wer über das
heißt nach den pulli stadt putin tragen
möchte und ja wir darüber reden was man
so machen kann wie belanglos fühlt es
sich für dich eigentlich an nachdem du
heute mit dem ukrainischen präsidenten
gesprochen hast ich würde gerne mal
deine einschätzung wissen auch was uns
eigentlich noch außenpolitisch
bevorstehen kann
nein das kommt für mich überhaupt nicht
belanglos denn ich glaube die frage wie
man vor allem sozial möglichen
konsequenzen umgeht ist eine wahnsinnig
wichtige und
leute wie ich oder wie du oder wie alle
die sozusagen in unserem publikum sitzen
die können das alles abfedern
möglicherweise ja können dann vielleicht
einmal weniger in urlaub fahren oder was
auch immer aber wir müssen uns ja auch
ehrlich machen wir sind ja diejenigen
die nicht mit einem kleinen einkommen
dort sitzen und die großen sorgen haben
dass irgendwie beim tanken sie nur noch
bestimmte liter füllen können und ich
glaube den größten fehler die wir in den
wir in der jetzigen situation machen
können ist zu sagen ja ihr müsst jetzt
alle für die ukraine dieses oder solches
tun ohne darüber zu sprechen was das
ganze für soziale folgen hat und
deswegen halte ich die debatte für
wahnsinnig wichtig und ich halte vor
allem wichtig dass man das eine thema
nicht gegen das andere aufwiegen also
ich mache mir sorgen darüber dass es
keinen sozialen ausgleich gibt und dass
das bedeutet dass am ende möglicherweise
menschen die eben ein geringeres
einkommen haben die ukraine oder oder
andere probleme dafür verantwortlich
machen dass ihre dass das ihre
wirtschaftlichen folgen ist und dass das
am ende dann auch wieder putin sieg
bedeuten könnte und vielleicht doch und
dass wir auch erklären und ich glaube
dass ich die rolle der medien extrem
wichtig politik natürlich also politiker
politikerinnen aber eben auch die medien
dass wir erklären das sind keine
luxusprobleme
wenn putin sich durchsetzt wenn wir es
nicht schaffen mit sanktionen ihn oder
den zirkel rund um ihn dazu zu bringen
zu erkennen was für kosten für ihn diese
politik bringt dann ist die gefahr dass
diese aggression weitergeht wenn die
ukraine hier diesen krieg verliert wenn
sich putin mit der brutalität eines us
oder seine eigenen strategien durchsetzt
dann ich habe es vor einigen tagen schon
gesagt ist es durchaus realistisch dass
wir zehn millionen oder mehr ukrainische
flüchtlinge aufnehmen müssen weil dann
die frauen und kinder die jetzt fliehen
vor den bomben die wir zum glück mit
großer empathie ganz europa hat gesagt
sie können kommen sie kriegen status in
deutschland das ist unglaublich wie
viele leute sich jetzt mobilisieren sie
unterzubringen aber bis jetzt sind zwei
millionen gekommen es könnten zehn
millionen werden und wenn putin den
krieg gewinnt in der ukraine dann werden
auch die männer und väter dieser frauen
und kinder nachkommen weil sie nicht in
diesem dunklen von mosca beherrschten
mehr in dieser ukrainischen kolonie der
identität und freiheit ausgelöscht wird
leben werden wollen und das heißt wenn
wir jetzt kurzfristig kosten haben in
der hoffnung diese katastrophale
entwicklung für die ukraine aber auch
für ganz europa abzuwenden dann ist es
wichtig dass die medien das er wird dann
ist es wichtig dass die politiker das
auch so erklären es geht hier nicht um
irgendwelche
idealistischen träumereien es geht darum
diese sanktionen diese kosten die
botschaft dass wir es ernst meinen ist
für unsere eigene sicherheit und für den
wohlstand nicht für die nächsten zwei
sondern für die nächsten zehn jahre und
für das europa in dem unsere kinder
leben werden
existenziell
erhalten haben wir zu spät reagiert kam
die botschaft zu spät dass frage
übrigens jeden politiker in der runde
der seit nächten in ihrem ehemaligen amt
zu tun
fraglos es ist zu spät
reagiert worden und wer trägt die
politik die regierung trägt die politik
man hätte natürlich früher diese gefahr
erkennen müssen nun ist es natürlich ein
bisschen wohl falsch hinterher ist man
immer schlauer
das kann man kann man immer dagegen
halten in welcher hinsicht sind sie
heute schlauer als damals oder als den
letzten jahren gibt es auch ein punkt wo
sie sagen da lag ich falsch es gibt ganz
ganz simplen punkt wo ich wo ich falsch
lagen mit mir wahrscheinlich millionen
andere ich hätte tatsächlich nicht
geglaubt dass das putin militärischer
eingeht ich habe das und das gebe ich
frank und frei zu weil ich eben nicht
hügel sondern ich stehe dann auch dazu
ich habe vor wenigen wochen noch gedacht
diesen schritt wird er nicht tun weil er
zu seinem schaden ist und ich hätte ihn
für klüger gehalten aber offensichtlich
ist er das nicht von also ich hab jetzt
überhaupt nicht auf moralische
kategorien gesetzt sie sehe ich bei dem
man nicht soll ich hab gedacht das ist
es wäre hochgradig unglück und zum
schaden seines landes wenn das tut und
wir sehen auch dass genau das jetzt
geschieht ich hab mich da geehrt ich war
mir am 21 2 als er gesagt hat er erkennt
hier beiden teilrepubliken im don was an
also sollen jetzt da war ich mir sicher
den nächsten tagen geht da rein aber er
ist da davor gehörte ich auch zu jenen
die gesagt haben ich halte es für ganz
unwahrscheinlich dass es wirklich zu
einer solchen militärischen eskalationen
kommt
wenn sie das wissen von heute jetzt
haben was würden sie sagen hätte die
politik auf sie jeder einzelne politiker
deine stimme hat in deutschland der
seine meinung sagen kann hätte man viel
früher bei mich wundert ist manchmal
dass es so lange natürlich auch weil ich
immer im austausch mit paul ronzheimer
bin weil wir die sendung hier zusammen
machen mich wundert ist so sehr dass so
spät also es wirklich auch menschen
gesehen und andere mit wird diese nicht
wusste dass es passieren wird wladimir
putin hat auch schon letzten sommer in
einem aufsatz gesagt gehabt also da hat
er der ukraine schon die eigentlich
abgesprochen die unabhängigen eigener
staat also es waren die vorzeichen waren
ja da so sehr
naja dass er diese begehrlichkeiten hat
das war durchaus sichtbar dass er sie
auf eine so brutale art und weise
tatsächlich militärisch umzusetzen
beginnen würde das habe ich nicht
geglaubt dass haben haben viele andere
auch nicht geglaubt nun kann man sagen
es hat vorzeichen gegeben man hätte das
sehen können das gab georgen in 2008 das
gab die krim annexion 2014 man konnte
das also tatsächlich durchaus erkennen
und da haben wir vielleicht tatsächlich
nicht genau genug hingeguckt wobei ich
an einer position festhalten möchte die
hier garantiert von niemand geteilt wird
das hätten wir tun müssen wir hatten ja
in der tat
energisch reagieren müssen aber die
gesprächskanäle sind tatsächlich zu
wenig offen gehalten worden das ist food
ihn mit einer arroganz des westens
begegnet worden dass eben nicht einfach
ein märchen sondern das ist so wenn da
muss man sich einmal vorstellen was
heißt das wenn obama davon spricht
rascher seien regional power das was
sollen solche demütigungen das ist nun
vollständig entfernt das recht fertig
leider nicht auf eine menge sendezeit
darauf hätte ich sehr gerne sehr hart
reagiert ich möchte aber jetzt dass paul
ronzheimer reagiert und die letzte
minute kriegt er jeden abend 30 sekunden
leider nur noch paul aber dass du ganz
schnell darauf reagiert
in diesen stunden in denen wir darüber
diskutieren was der westen machen kann
sterben weiter kinder und frauen ihren
der ukraine in mariupol wo dein
kinderkrankenhaus angegriffen wir gehen
davon aus dass es tausende tote gibt
vielleicht gibt es bei zehntausende
hunderttausende tote wenn der westen
wenn unsere regierung weiter so machen
wie sie jetzt tun ich glaube es muss
mehr getan werden dass dieser krieg
beendet wird das schlusswort gehört dir
paul vielen herzlichen dank an meine
gäste aber vor allem auch an dich schön
abend noch bis morgen abend
[Musik]